i was never allowed to be on social
media
as a teenager the first time i really
got personally exposed to these sorts of
platforms was at the age of 19
when i created my first instagram
account always having been a bit of a
weirdo one of the reasons being my lack
of social media
i always thought that finally
downloading them and joining them would
make me feel a bit more accepted what i
did not
expect however was instagram making me
feel
more like an outsider the platform has
always made me feel uneasy for various
reasons the fact that normal everyday
social norms do not seem to apply
the fact that its growth rates have
followed that of suicide rates of young
teenage girls
and in general at this point it feels
almost like a rebellion
to not be on the app which is absolutely
ridiculous in this video i have put
together the reasons that have made me
quit
instagram over the last few months let's
get started my first issue with it was
the fact that i felt that i was
surrounded by so many fake connections
and these were actually with people for
whom i carried a lot so people with whom
i hadn't been in contact with for a very
long time
who live in a different city or a
different country right now and people
that i really care for
but because i haven't actually talked to
them in such a long time by just leaving
likes on
their photos or by just leaving kind of
meaningless comments of a few hearts or
this looks great or congratulations on
your baby or graduation
i felt as though i was getting the
illusion that i was actually in touch
with these people
when in reality i really wasn't so in
the end of the day i was feeling much
more isolated ever since i've quit for
example when i've
thought of someone which i haven't
thought of in a very long time i'm much
more inclined to kind of send them a
message or
organize a call or a meet-up which is a
lot better and a lot more meaningful
than this oh yeah i know what's going on
with them because i've been following
their stories but it's not really that
connected at the end of the day now i
feel so much better even if i spent 15
minutes
on a facetime call with my mom than if i
would spend a few hours a day just
scrolling through instagram and being
connected with people i
like and care for there's an expression
that says that depression requires a
certain level of privacy and i feel like
that is the danger of social media
because while you are actually in
private and you don't have any
meaningless connections
you're under the illusion that you are
not so you end up feeling worse and
worse over the long term
next is that i see a huge difference in
the world online and in the world in
reality
i feel like people act very differently
on these two different platforms in
reality i feel like people are a lot
kinder
they are a lot more accepting there's a
lot more jokes and forgiveness when
mistakes are there
people are very genuinely supportive and
kind while online i see people saying
things and doing things that i've
never seen in real life and it just
makes me feel quite sad when i'm
surrounded by so much negativity this
beautiful show that one of my favorite
people they're around us
um regarding anonymity and the fact that
when we think that we are anonymous and
people don't know who we are
everyone is much more likely to be a lot
more sinister and to cause harm onto
other people i do genuinely think that
social media can bring out the worst in
all of us and
i just don't like to be in that sort of
environment next i feel like social
media was setting goals in my life that
i never really wanted now i don't feel
as though i'm the sort of person who
compares myself to others a lot
but despite that when i was on instagram
i was often feeling
that my exam grades weren't good enough
that i wasn't doing enough with my life
that i'm not
dressed well enough that i don't have
enough bags or
electronic devices or i'm not going on
good enough holidays or to nice enough
restaurants it was absolutely
ridiculous not only did i have to fight
against this constant promotion of
consumerism
but i felt very often brought down and
feeling as though the things that i saw
around me were not good enough on social
media we just picked the best
parts of our lives to show and it
creates this skewed picture
of normalizing things that are just not
normal most people that i know in
reality are not going to
amazing holidays very very often or
multiple times a year
most people that i know do not own
chanel bags most people that i know are
not going to amazing restaurants and
crazy parties every single weekend so i
feel as though when i'm surrounded by
only real life people and not their
online versions of themselves i am
comparing myself to their real life
personas which is a lot more healthy
than comparing myself to their online
personas which can
make me feel very very bad next has to
do with the instagram algorithm
and i very often hear people telling me
that oh if you just wait on instagram
long enough
your feed will turn into what you want
it to see because instagram will show
you what you want
and i disagree with this the algorithm
is programmed to show us what we are
interested in and what we are spending
time on
and not what we like or what is good for
us and these two things
are vastly different sometimes i'm
interested in things which are actually
not that good for me
i can go down rabbit holes that are
making me feel worse and worse but i
just can't tear my eyes away from
and all the algorithm will know is that
this is content that i am likely to
spend my time on so it will show more
and more of it to me
so my feeds don't tend to be healthy
they're not only funny memes and jokes
but they are very often
things that just make me feel sad and
unhappy just because i find them
interesting and i love the expression
that as a human being it is our
responsibility
to create ourselves to the decisions we
make and the environments we choose and
as we'll find
we have been creating ourselves all
along even if unintentionally i feel as
though this is definitely what's
happening
with instagram because the default
option has become to have it it feels as
though
you are not making a choice and you're
just doing what is normal and what is
average by staying on this platform
while
even not making a choice and staying on
it is a decision so i felt for me
personally
i needed to kind of take action in
designing what i'm doing and because
instagram has generally not brought many
sort of benefits to my life i think it
was a lot healthier to curate my days
and my experience of consuming things
around
not having instagram at all there's this
phrase that says you start playing
because you want to have fun
but then you continue playing because
you want to avoid being unhappy
and this was definitely what happened
with me when it came
to instagram so i felt like it was
genuinely time for me to just stop and
leave
something that prompted me to make this
video was a documentary that i saw
on the like button it touches not only
on the history of it and how it came to
be
but also how it has shaped our
psychology as a society
in making it acceptable to like or
dislike things and how it affects us and
our everyday life this was a very very
eye-opening experience for me it's not a
very long documentary i would definitely
recommend that you watch it
um i saw it on curiositystream which are
very kindly sponsoring this video
as i'm trying to be a bit more
intentional with my online consumerism
curiosity stream is definitely up there
with the things that i
do like to spend my time on it has a
bunch of documentaries which are very
well filmed
very well short and just leave me
feeling great if you stand for curiosity
stream which is actually
ridiculously cheap you also get access
to nebula which is a platform
where a bunch of us creators are putting
our videos out for you to see with no
ads
so you can get access to both of these
by following the link in my description
and the last thing i wanted to mention
is something that i was actually quite
nervous about
putting in this video because i have
mentioned it before and i think
i've gotten some strong reactions either
way about it but honestly i have gone
into a lot of thoughts and i completely
agree with it so
i'm just going to say it i think that
the underlying message of putting
anything on social media
is give me attention and i will say i'm
the first person involved in this
obviously because this is what i am
doing right now um so i'm definitely
very very guilty of it but i do
genuinely feel that by posting selfies
of ourselves or putting ourselves out
there
or just posting even a picture of the
food that we're having
whatever we are saying on the surface is
that oh i'm having a great time or this
was very delicious or this was very fun
but what we're saying underneath that i
feel is give me attention and even
though i'm definitely not above that cry
and that need for attention from other
people and there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that to you know a
certain extent it is normal
and healthy i just think that promoting
it so much and normalizing it so much is
perhaps
not that healthy and i think it makes
one pay a lot more attention inwardly
onto ourselves and our attention is not
always positive
i do think it can give us the illusion
that what we are doing or what we are
posting has
some sort of great importance when it
perhaps
doesn't and and i do think that when you
are social media there is this extra
work that you need to do
to stay humble and to like yourself for
who you are and to be a bit more
accepting and kind to other people and i
just think that this was something that
at the end of the day
i just didn't want to keep doing so when
it comes to instagram at the end of the
day
there are some things about it that i do
miss i do miss posting stories because
it's such a good way to interact with
people
it's such a good way to have a pulse and
it's such a good way to get a huge
amount of responses from you guys on
things that i
perhaps want to do or questions that i
want to ask or if i want to do a
sit-down
q a while i'm painting which i really
want to do um i feel like
instagram is actually the best place to
do this i just wish there was a way that
i could just turn off all of my feeds i
could turn off my homepage i can turn
off my
my kind of discovery page and there
would just be nothing
there i feel like then i would love the
platform i know that it's incredibly
selfish to not want to interact with
anything on instagram but to ask
other people to interact with me but i
honestly wish that there was a middle
ground that i could agree with at this
point i don't think that i am deleting
my account because i think that that
interaction
function is very very helpful and
something that i might use in the future
so i think the way that i'm going to
approach social media from now on is not
that i'm going to have social media
and then take some breaks from it but
rather that i'm not going to have social
media and i'm going to take some breaks
for my breaks
when i just want to post a q a or just
get some interactions here and there
that i might need
for this channel so i think that's the
way that i'm going to approach it in the
future
i don't really see myself kind of
posting a lot on it or going
back to it fully because there's just
too much that i dislike about that
platform so yes that was everything for
this quite
rampy video if you made it so far thank
you so much for spending this time with
me i would love to hear
what your approach is to social media or
how you can make platforms like
instagram actually work if there are
ways
you can kind of avoid some of these
problems i would love to hear them
i hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be kind to yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye